my name is Eric Prather and I'm a sleep
scientist at UCSF I study that causes
and consequences of insufficient sleep
and I also carry out interventions to
improve sleep among people with insomnia
today I've been challenged to explain
the topic of sleep at five different
levels everybody knows a little bit
about what is happening when they sleep
but I think they'll be surprised that
there's a lot of science in there
Christopher hey Christopher and how old
are you I'm 10 what great is that
I think fifth think what is your
favorite subject in science well that's
awesome because we're gonna be talking
about science today cool hey you know
we're gonna be talking about what sleep
of the day mine too cuz I get to spend
all day studying it cuz you know what
sleep does for you body's like an
electric car
that's exactly right it kinda is like
recharging your battery right and sleep
is so critical for so many parts of our
body in our mind right it plays a really
important way that we learn and it helps
us kind of recover from the day before
it affects our immune system and our
metabolism all of these things that we
need to kind of be healthy so today
we're gonna talk about some animals and
how they sleep so here's the first one
what's that a giraffe have you ever seen
a giraffe in person oh they're pretty
cool right huh and so what's really cool
about this is that giraffes need to
sleep like everybody else and so the way
that it does is it kind of kind of
slumps over and it gets down on its legs
and it kind of becomes this ball but
what's crazy about the whole thing is
they only sleep for like 30 minutes a
day 30 minutes because it can't waste
any more time because it can't be
vulnerable for any longer it can get
eaten by lions and that kind of thing it
is kind of evolved in a way that it can
still survive and still get all the
restoration it needs under such a short
period of time like recharge really
humans so we think it works the same way
but maybe just like more efficiently and
so we're still really learning about how
this works
sleep science itself is kind of a new
field I had to sleep over on Saturday
and I didn't sleep at all and how did
you feel
tired really tired do you think you were
a little crankier than usual yeah that's
actually really interesting because what
happens is humans and everything needs
to sleep eventually and so you can't
stay up indefinitely right what do you
think happens if you don't sleep it
affects what you can do in your daily
life excellent so now I want to tell you
about another animal and how they sleep
okay so we have this one what's that a
hippo hippopotamus they have a different
challenge
they sleep underwater right right so how
do they do it in the in the area that
they live they need to stay cool right
and so they spent a lot of time in the
water and so then as a consequence they
need to sleep in the water but how do
they do it
so it's really fascinating what they do
is while they're sleeping they actually
float back up to the surface and breathe
without waking up they're able to go
about their whole sleep cycles but still
able to breathe because their body has
adapted in a way that they can still get
the oxygen that they need it's it's it's
a really amazing thing what do you think
that's cool would it be cool to have
that power oh yeah
so now I want to talk about our last
animal and I think this one is probably
the most amazing of all okay so what's
this oh I don't think a dolphin yes
so dolphins kind of like hippos have to
sleep in the water okay but because
they're mammals right they need to
breathe
dolphins breathe air they have to go up
to the surface and breathe right and for
an animal like that it can get eaten it
needs to figure out a way that it can
sleep but also still survive right you
know what how dolphins sleep one half of
their brain at a time so half of their
brain goes to sleep and the other half
stays awake so that they can continue to
breathe and swim and they do it in this
for hours at a time so like their right
part of their brain sleeps they're able
to go up to the surface and breathe then
the left part of their brain sleeps for
four hours and it goes back and forth
back and forth so that they can kind of
maintain alertness still breathe and
survive is that amazing or what
that's cool so what'd you learn today
I learn how other animals sleep what is
important about sleeping sleep rests
your body and you have to rest your body
in order to do your daily things in life
hey I'm Eric I'm doing nice teacher and
how old are you doing I'm 16 years old
okay where do you go to school
MacLaren's high school in Oakland
California excellent and what's your
favorite subject ap chemistry that's a
serious scientist and good news we're
talking about science today
yeah in fact we're talking about sleep
and sleep science do you sleep I do I
try you try but we all gotta try you've
probably heard about sleep as this kind
of you know it's a biological process
that happens in your brain it's really
important to your body but it's it's a
lot more complex than that
sleep is made up of different parts and
you know when you think about sleep what
do you think about resting relaxing
really shutting down your brain taking
some time off and a busy schedule and
you know a work day but being off is
just not being off there's lots of
things that are happening we're gonna
kind of talk about those different
pieces of sleep okay so our sleep is is
made up of different types okay the
first one is called non rapid eye
movement sleep or non REM okay or n REM
and then the other one which is you know
might not be a surprise
it's called REM rapid eye movement sleep
and those are the the two main types of
sleep that happen the way that we
measure that as a sleep scientist is we
actually will bring people into the lab
or they can do this at home where we put
electrodes on their scalp while they're
sleeping and then allows us to measure
the brain activity that's going on
during the night okay are you like able
to tell how much sleep someone's getting
or what their sleep schedule is by REM
when we measure all of that we're able
to see you know how much time someone's
asleep and how many how many times they
wake up and stuff during the night you
know we're also really interested in
kind of the amount of non REM sleep that
someone gets and the amount of REM sleep
that someone gets because each part of
those types of sleep do different things
for the body and so it's important to
get both of those and so within non REM
sleep
there are three stages ranging from n1
to n2 to end
so not particularly clever in our naming
but that's how we know what stages they
are and what they do is as it moves from
lightest to deepest sleep okay and so an
n1 it's more kind of light wakefulness
sleep kind of kind of in and out of
sleeping then you go into n2 which is
where we spend 45 to 55 percent of our
sleep and it's it's more this kind of
light sleep but then we get into kind of
the the really restorative sleep and
that's n3 and in n3 when we look at
someone's eg wave we see these big slow
waves and it's called slow wave sleep
and so we spend about you know 20% of
our sleep and in slow wave sleep though
it can vary on a day to day ok when do
you think you experience the most of
Rama well I've heard that you don't
really go in till I could deeper sleep
so I'm guessing like in 3 or any of the
ends that are really if you are on
technology right before you go to sleep
and also if you like if there's so much
light or if you are listening to music
while you're asleep or anything like
that like you're not experienced with
deep sleep right you know some of that
is is totally accurate that like you
know when you your brains more engaged
by being on your phone or you know doing
things that you really enjoy or things
that stress you out or any of those
types of things it's harder to get to
sleep and to kind of fall into that
deeper levels of sleep most of the REM
sleep
this dreaming sleep happens in the
second half of the night okay so we wake
up a lot during the night and we just
don't remember it and then you'll go
back down into deep sleep and then you
know up again into REM and you know and
the kind of these these cycles right do
you ever take naps I do okay how long
that how long are the naps that you take
anywhere between 1 to 6 hours 1 to 6
hours yes that's a long nap ok usually
we want to keep naps like like 20 or 30
minutes when people drop into deep sleep
and then they're walkin up out of a nap
most people report that they feel way
worse than they did before they took the
nap and that's because you've been in
deep sleep and it's this term called
sleep inertia so what are what are the
stages of sleep so in one being like
light you know sleep still a lot of
brain activity going
I can imagine that that happens right
after you fall asleep asleep and into
being light moderate activity in your
brain still sleep but still kind of
consciously aware and then 3 being the
deepest form of sleep I want to know if
you agree sleep is the coolest thing
you've ever heard of it really is right
now is definitely the coolest thing I've
ever heard of so tell me you know where
are you in school what do you study
I'm a fourth year chemistry student at
USF it's a pretty science II yes pretty
science II excellent because today for
this level we're talking about sleep
great how much sleep do you get
typically during the summer like German
our turnout during the school year maybe
five Wow yeah so how much do you think
you need I mean I've read that six is
ideal for people in my age range turns
out so for people that are between the
ages of 18 and 65 the agreed upon amount
of sleep that people should get is
between seven and nine hours and it's
really at least seven hours per night to
maintain optimal health as an adult so
at least seven hours when we look at
across all of the the data that is
available on like sleep and health and
sleep in psychiatric illness and those
types of things the largest risk is when
people get five hours or less what do
you think kind of is responsible for
driving kind of how much sleep you need
and things like that I mean I know sleep
is kind of regulated by the thalamus and
the suprachiasmatic nucleus sending
signals to the pineal gland which kind
of secretes melatonin which tells us
like when it's time to go to sleep and
right you can do part of this level I
will do the other part clearly got some
expertise under your belt and so that's
awesome because I think that everyone
should know more about sleep and so the
way that we think about what drives
sleep are two kind of independent but
kind of related processes and so they
have kind of lame names process s and
process C ok what you've kind of
described is process C and that's the
master clock right and it helps Rea
kind of the rhythms like all of your
body all your cells and all those kind
of things it drives the release of
melatonin from the pineal gland and
melatonin comes online under darkness so
when the Sun Goes Down your brain knows
okay it's it's time to start getting
ready for sleep and so you start
releasing melatonin which really kind of
sets the table for sleeping like I'm
from Hawaii so we have very long days we
have early sun rises late Sun sets does
that signify like less sleep because we
have a shorter amount of time for
militant ends to be released yeah no
that's a really great question and the
same thing is true you know in places
where the Sun never goes down during the
summer and when it's dark all time
during the winter it turns out that
light isn't the only thing that kind of
gates your circadian rhythm but I think
the thing that's really important is
again there are two processes but the
other one is the s process and that
one's just kind of a really important
driver of sleep and its formal name we
call it like the homeostatic sleep drive
kind of the longer you're awake
the sleepier you get you stay up you get
sleepy time goes by you get sleepy air
time goes by you get sleep here but it's
actually kind of a really fundamental
principle for how sleep is regulated and
it's really kind of a kin to like a
balloon okay so you know you wake up in
the morning and your balloon is flat
like you kind of like drained out all
the sleepiness but then as you kind of
go throughout the day it kind of fills
up right so you can use your energy it
gets filled up and it gets filled up
more like as you get towards nighttime
right and then when it's at like this
optimal amount is when you kind of like
go to sleep again this is really what
underlies kind of wide napping can also
be bad for you so napkins aren't
inherently bad but if you know you
actually let out some of this air during
the day it's gonna take longer for the
balloon to get bigger right and where
you feel sleepy right okay what did you
learn about sleep today I learned about
the two processes process and process
see I learned about their circadian
rhythm and how it doesn't only rely on
like melatonin but it also relies on
your eating and like a whole bunch of
other factors that kind of affect your
circadian rhythm hi I'm Eric maze thank
you for joining us what do you do or yet
so I'm at UC Berkeley I'm a psychology
student studying cognitive neuroscience
and I just started my third year
congratulations thank you so so a lot of
brain stuff a lot of brain stuff great
I'm biased because I study one of the
others of critical parts of the brain
the cerebellum so that's good because
that's that's why you're here and so
we're talking about sleep today and
really about kind of what is the brain
machinery through which we go from kind
of consciousness to unconsciousness and
that transition great okay the best way
to think about this transition is really
called up it's a flip-flop switch okay
and so this term comes from engineering
and the idea is that in sleep you
basically have kind of this
all-or-nothing kind of experience you
know certainly people kind of drift off
to sleep but then also in your
unconscious right so it seems like it's
this flip-flop between kind of the
arousal system and then the sleep
promoting system and it's it's certainly
regulated and well and we'll get a
little bit into that but there's
certainly kind of made up of two
reciprocally inhibitory processes okay
so we have the ascending reticular
activating system it originates in the
brainstem and there's a dorsal and
ventral arm to this and so the the
dorsal arm has neurons cholinergic
neurons that go up to the thalamus and
then it you know projections into the
forebrain and then there's the the
ventral arm and this is comprised of a
whole bunch of different types of
neurons that are all monomineralic
so there's kind of dopaminergic neurons
that come from the periaqueductal gray
serotonergic ones from the dorsal raphe
nuclei histamine nergic neurons that
come from the tuber mammillary nucleus
of the hypothalamus and then nor
adrenergic neurons from the locus
realice and so all of those are kind of
working in tandem to kind of drive wake
within the brain and you know so if we
just think about kind of drugs that are
available for inducing wakefulness we
can you know it's certainly kind of the
dopaminergic ones kind of jump out right
so we have kind of in feta means that
certainly kind of dry those signaling
and then modafinil which is a wake
promoting drug for people that have kind
of excessive daytime sleepiness that it
maintains alertness throughout the day
in terms of the dopamine
is you know if you're taking
amphetamines that's usually to promote
as you said wakefulness but does that
actually improve the quality of your
sleep how reliable are those kinds of
interventions the role that they play
with respect to the sleep/wake system is
really kind of amping up the weak system
right and so certainly that has like
downstream consequences for the sleep
system because now the flip-flops which
is kind of pushed you know in a much
stronger direction and we have to kind
of rely on what regulates sleep to kind
of get it pushed back to sleep and do we
know much about why or which like which
stages are the sleep Skycycle are
affected you know if you take
amphetamines as a sign when you go to
sleep you're not able to transition
through each of the different sleep
periods or no I think that's what's
clear in some ways you know getting back
to this idea of this wake sleep system
you know we have this sleep system that
is kind of the counterpoint to to this
wake arousal system and so that the
primary nucleus region is the ventral
lateral preoptic nucleus they also
called VLP oh and that has particular
neuron outputs that release GABA and
Gamelin which work in an inhibitory way
on kind of the the weight promoting ones
and so it's this kind of delicate
balance of these two systems that are
ongoing and your cognitive neuroscience
training right it sounds like it's you
know pretty specific and focus in a
particular part of the brain the
cerebellum and I one thing that I'm kind
of interested in it's a you bring a
participant into the study have you
ensured that they got a good night's
sleep have you asked them about that in
most studies probably it is advised for
eight participants before they come in
to get a good night's sleep so those
would be recommendations that you would
lay out you know in communication with
the participant before they come in
you know what we do in our studies is we
actually track people for say a week and
they have to kind of get in within this
range of amount of sleep and then it has
to be both amount of sleep and then how
kind of stable it is that variability
can really impact it and certainly might
have an
packed on the machinery that's happening
in the brain often think that people
many people think that they can get by
and very little sleep or less than
average meant of sleep but from what I
know from the research you know if you
actually test those people on different
batteries of cognitive tasks you'll
often find that they their performance
is is slightly worse than maybe they had
anticipated yeah so what what did you
learn about sleep today I guess I
learned that it's a system that is you
know very heavily regulated and
influenced by you know some of these
older more conserved subcortical systems
in the brain and that there's as you
called it like a flip flop flop function
between wakefulness and and sleep that's
regulated by these specific like
dopaminergic neurons energy like
neurotransmitters that manifest in
different sub critical parts of the
brain so now we have sleep on your brain
that was they all I wanted to hear good
to see you again you a yes really glad
that you could join us so we've been
talking about sleep today at various
levels of complexity but now with you I
really want to talk about kind of what
do we know about sleep and the aging
brain can you tell me a lot about some
of the work that you've been doing in
that area so I'm a pathologist so we do
a lot of work on the epidemiology of
sleep and development of
neurodegenerative diseases including
both Alzheimer's and Parkinson's disease
so a dmpd we make me work on population
studies we work on thousands and even
millions of population and we use
statistical modeling to find out the
association between different sleep
disturbances and also genetics related
to sleep disturbances and linked that to
their risk of developing AD and Pt so
how strong is the link our study has
found really strong associations looking
at these populations for example with
sleep apnea
we've done one meta-analysis and it
showed that those with sleep apnea they
have us ratio of one point two six which
means that those
have sleep apnea they have 26% elevated
risk of developing Alzheimer's compared
to those without sleep apnea well it's
essentially cuz I so so I also saw that
there was a recent meta-analysis around
sleep disturbances and dementia risk and
in that study they looked at about
250,000 people in this meta-analysis and
they followed them for around 10 years
you know when they pulled all the
samples together and they found there
was a 1.2 fold risk increased risk for
developing all cause dementia and so it
sounds like both sleep apnea and then
maybe sleep disturbances more generally
are associated with increased risk for
dementia when I think about that I think
about how sleepily lives in the brain
these nerds jenner disease live in the
brain and so what do we know about the
causality of this could it be that
individuals who have early onset of say
Alzheimer's have then kind of poor sleep
as a consequence of that yeah so I think
what's really fascinating is all these
bi-directional relationship that's being
identified in animal studies especially
sharing their sleep changes actually
occur very early on in the disease
process so it could be a proto normal
stage of Parkinson's and also in
transgenic mouse model of AD they are
already showing a lot of circadian
abnormalities in this mouse so within
dementia risk in particular Alzheimer's
for instance there are kind of two clear
features that seem to be part of the
pathology right so there's kind of beta
amyloid which accumulates in the brain
and there's kind of these tangles this
tau off at these right and so it sounds
like you know sleep seems to be related
to the tau off at these what about kind
of beta amyloid yes in the transgenic
mouse models of AD including those
expressing human mutant amyloid
precursor protein AP P tau of both so
that's kind of showing the sleep changes
in those of these pathologies okay so
there is this bi-directional piece but I
think you know perhaps the most exciting
thing that happened in this sleep field
at least in my view has been
understanding the role of sleep and it's
clearance of beta amyloid
brain this idea that sleep is like the
dishwasher of the brain it seems like
that you know
a bat beta accumulates as we kind of use
energy and you know it's it's kind of
you know it's a waste product and the
idea that if you don't clear it out then
it's going to build up and accumulate so
the thing I'm most excited about sleep
research is I think first of all this
complexity of the daytime nighttime
sleep what sleep is really doing to our
body and to our brain and then is really
from the epidemiologic or public health
perspective how we can best use sleep as
a tool for the detection and Prevention
of neuro degeneration in the long-term
I'm excited about the kind of the future
of sleep medicine I think there are
incredible innovations that are
happening in the basic sciences kind of
really starting to understand what are
the clear biological processes that
underlie some of these things as they
relate to disease risk and what is the
true function of sleep kind of the why
we sleep phenomenon right so this was
certainly a challenge today everyone
knew a little bit about sleep and I
think that's great because sleep is
incredibly important but there was also
a lot of misinformation around kind of
how sleep works and people doing sleep
behaviors that may not be the most
adaptive for them we're still uncovering
new things every day about how sleep
works but despite that all of us know
that sleep is fundamental to our health
and so I'm excited for sleep to kind of
raise its profile among other health
behaviors and get the investment and
care that it needs
[Music]